man I wish I had me a icecream snicker
bruh dude I love ice cream snicker um
I've look if I'm a treat myself to
something's gonna be an ice cream
snicker anyway today's episode is
brought to you by gray block pizza gray
block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles also
bronx-born pizza up in Bend Oregon both
those places are swaggy spots where you
can get fully Italian go and get that
hitter today's episode is brought to you
by better help.com now better help it's
a great place man I have used this it is
counselling it is mental health therapy
if you if you have something as bugging
you something that's bothering you
you're uncomfortable sharing this is a
place you can share they have
professional and affordable counseling
I've had three meetings with the
counselor on there and it is it's it's
helpful you can get matched with the
counselor who's right for you there are
four communication modes text chat phone
and video you can start communicating in
under 24 hours you must be 18 or over
it's available worldwide not intended
for those actively considering suicide
it's available on desktop mobile web
Android and iOS apps schedule video and
phone sessions with real licensed
counselors it works
I'm telling you firsthand it works go to
better help calm slash Theo th e oh
that's better help calm slash Theo
lastly today's episode is brought to you
by a we're study aware is one of the
largest studies ever conducted think
about a study and think about people
conducting studies and they got hammers
and they got you know scalp EULA's and
they got you know you know notebooks and
a we're study is one of the largest
studies ever conducted this trying to
understand the relationship between mood
and PTSD so veterans and their families
can live healthier and happier lives you
can help our veterans by by checking
this out and and becoming part of the
study aware is sponsored by the US
Department
of Veteran Affairs and overlap health
what's awesome about this study is that
it's only 28 days long you don't even
need to have PTSD so that's a bonus or
you don't even have to be a veteran all
you have to be pretty much is alive all
you have to be is alive it is to be over
the age of 18 be alive and live in the
US and speak some English dude
anybody can speak some English think
about it even if you only went to eighth
grade it's really easy to use those
download the aware study app from the
App Store or Play Store fill out some
baseline questions and you can be part
of the study you'll see your mood change
in over the month and you'll get little
tools to help you in the moment when
you're feeling sad or you're feeling a
little down and you're feeling like you
you know somebody just beat you upside
the balls with the blues well everything
will change for you go to a where study
org that's a where study dot org and
download on iOS or Android today all
right thank you guys for being here just
got back from Chicago and I'm happy I'm
happy to be here man [ __ ] what am I
I don't know I'm here man I'm here let's
go
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate man
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die
[Music]
there you go that is Spencer Jacob grab
and enough Spencer Jacob growl and and
and that song that was for eight months
a year that was our intro music remember
that guys all them Wildcats out there
that was our intro music that was the
song we used every single week time
after time that was our intro music man
I just saw my Instagram feed somebody
put up some shot of this some real like
in a swimsuit man Instagram so dangerous
because look you'll be doing you look
you'll be putting you know you'll be
about to read a bedtime story to a child
you've got to read a bedtime story - a
little damn child you know and then you
look at Instagram just for a second you
latch on just take a peek and they got
some somebody showing their breasts out
or some ladies saying oh just got back
from the dentist and all she gots is a
little and it's like her backside with a
little piece of just floss going through
that ace like what look at the under
bite on that fricking camel toe right
there what's going on I mean it's just
the problem is it's a Pandora's box
that's what I'm saying about instagrams
because you go in there you know you're
waiting for your kid your kids in the in
the in the toilet you know when he's
brushing his teeth and he's in the
toilet and he's brushing his teeth and
you're the you're the dad you're a
parent maybe you're a parent or your
uncle who people trust and you got the
kid and aeri brushing up and you're like
imma sit on a bed I'm gonna be a good
parent I'm gonna be a good role model
I'm gonna read a storybook to the child
maybe you're gonna read him one of those
fancy books you know horton hears a who
or you know one of the the Spike Lee
autobiography I don't know whatever you
read the kids are Amelia Bedelia is
and then so you pet you the kids taking
a long time to brush his teeth because
he's a [ __ ] kid
you know and they don't know what
they're doing I remember our neighbor
one time came over and he's supposed to
brush his teeth dude he filled his whole
mouth with an entire tube of toothpaste
and then just just swallowed it you're
like what what happened and he thought
he brushed his teeth and it was like no
he didn't brush him he is an idiot but
so the kids in there next thing you know
finally the kid comes in the room but
you just peeked at your phone and you
see a girl it's like oh you know just
came back from Mike you know from my
great grandfather's funeral and she just
has a pair of like you know breasts and
you're like what would have that have to
do with the funeral
it's just Instagram is that Pandora's
box you have to be careful we got to be
careful of our phones you know I noticed
when I get up in the morning I can't
look at that phone man if I look at the
fat the first thing I do is look at my
phone for me my day is not gonna be good
it's not gonna be good because that mean
that Pandora that means the devil the
devil lives in this rectangle in that
rectangle phone or if you have a
surround phone or something like that
the devil lives in there and they will
get you out of the gate they will get
you by the gunt
thank you guys for joining me thank
everybody that came out in Chicago man
what a time sold out all the shows we
went to the Laugh Factory I've never
been in this club before so thank you
for people that came out there for the
first time the staff was amazing look
man there's a guy Curtis that is the
manager there and this white dude named
Brian that's a manager over there and
man those boys the swaggiest squad ever
I mean just from top to bottom good
people over there taking care of
everything
you know just hustling you know did so
much to help out me because I just had a
stressful I sort up kind of stressed up
and they um you know they just helped me
out you know somebody gave me a little
neck massage boy and look a lot of
people go get parts of their body
massage and they get their leg
eggs are there but or you know sometimes
you can just you know drive down the
street by your neighbors and somebody
will just put a thumb in you ask for a
little bit and shake it around you know
that old [ __ ] you know that giving
that baby hitchhiker you know that
old-school massage boy you know that
Benedict Arnold just sneak up around
your ass but um but they had somebody
there gave me a little neck massage and
do look I say this man you know I never
been erotic with another man or anything
like that and I'm not saying I won't be
one day when I'm 70 or 80 after I've had
a family maybe a wife or two you know
I'm i duck out with a know you know with
an urban guy with a little Asian
gentleman
maybe I slip out with some little soft
little boy you know not boy man I mean a
soft little JIT you know male I might
slip out with some little soft little
bad bad Benjamin maybe we move off to a
special island or something and uh you
know is a White Nile out there with
Morgan Freeman's or whatever and he out
there building a boat and and maybe we
get out there we don't you know I don't
think I'm gonna be doing anything sexual
with dude but I might be out there we
might stay up at night and play checkers
or do something you know you know play
you know do some [ __ ] you know
aggressive thumb wrestling but that's it
but anyway what I'm saying is this [ __ ]
was I saying
man I forgot oh but they had a man dude
I had a dude over there he convinced me
he's like look you know he's like look
look look look I'm gonna break you off
this neck massage and this dude
[Music]
brothers dude massage my neck so much
man it felt I do my neck felt like he
wanted to say something and I was and I
didn't even know what my neck was gonna
say man my neck felt like hit it like it
had been saving upwards of its own
instead of me forcing these words all
these different words through my neck
over the years my neck was like none no
I'm about to say something my own and
that's how good the massage was it that
that that uh that young man put on my
neck boy you know he's
frickin uh you know he's that um he's
that real you know he's dad that neck
man you know he's you know captain neck
and he neck you know the dude got my
neck right you know he got my neck right
but I had a good time in Chicago we had
a great time with the single mom we took
out a lovely single mom and her friend
she's a dance instructor at at Columbia
College in Chicago and she was very
charming she has a six-year-old daughter
and man we had a blast
we went and sat in the greenroom
together and did some paintings we had a
painting contest this was pretty fun and
they were super patient and we had a
painting contest and we each painted a
clown and you know a clown is comedians
worst nimis that's our that is our
number one worst nemesis and you know a
lot of my nemesis's are turpentine
clowns what else
diseases and a clown um so the three of
us she brought her girl she brought her
girlfriend a friend of hers who was a
female and uh and then we had a good
time we just joke we joked around and we
chatted we talked about relationships
and stuff like that and she was a really
strong and uh and just wise woman and
she was fun she was a lot of fun man it
was nice and it was nice we just spend
some time together you know we just
spent some time together and we made it
we painted these clowns and then the
early show if you were at the Early Show
on Saturday
you got to the audience got to judge
whose clown was the best and mine came
in second our single moms came in third
and her friend her friends came in first
and I don't want to put her on blast but
Raquel as uh is her name I just I
couldn't decide if it was you know yeah
you know yeah say her name that is her
name Raquel beautiful lady and and we
had fun man it was cool when they you
know and it her and her friend they
would every now and then they just break
out these little dance moves and they
was you know showing daddy a little bit
of that twerk twerk but it was great so
I want to thank our patreon errs for
supporting that
and and we did it man we got out there
and did it and we're gonna get teen to
do awesome things through the podcast
and and just keeping our mindset to not
think about ourselves that's one of my
long term goals is to just get tired of
thinking about myself man
it's almost exhausting isn't it you know
for me sometimes it gets so exhausting
over the years just to all the just
concern I've had for myself just like
and it's not even selfishness sometimes
it's just you know sometimes when you
grow up with anxiety or you grow up with
being worried a lot you just are like
you're just so aware you're so hyper
aware of everything that you know you're
just always like such a um it's like
you're just like a security guard for
yourself at all times and it can just be
exhausting over the years so I'm glad as
I get a little bit older to be able to
start to just let all let a little bit
of that out a little bit of that steam
out of my out of my steam tank what else
what else happened
oh the oh oh we we sold some shirts at
the shows if your shirt some of the
printer the the shirt printer he the
shirt someone he made him off it was
off-center so if you got a bad shirt
send us an email through the website
with a picture of it and we will we'll
we'll get you a reimbursement and I want
to apologize about that if anybody
bought a bad shirt we didn't know we
didn't know but Chicago was great and I
want to thank everybody that came out I
also had a dude I went to Nashville so
uh after last week's episode I left I
left the studio went to the airport and
I went to Nashville out to leapers Fork
Tennessee and and shot a video at Bishop
gun and I was in a dang country music
video and so I'm a straight up fit one
of them video vixens and it was uh
did I was in the south I mean I was out
there out in biscuit country like you
know you smell somebody's breath and
everybody's breath smelt like biscuits
you know everybody's breath smelled like
deer meat and everybody got a little bit
of uh you know deer urine back behind
there
earlobes you know to try and get other
deers to come out because the crazy
thing about deers
if you're trying to shoot a deer this is
do when you think about the things that
hunters go through that hunters go
through to try and shoot a deer first of
all they go and get another deer to piss
in a jug okay which i think is [ __ ]
insane you know unless you're trying to
get that deer to play football for you
or something you don't trust it and you
don't trust some of its workout methods
but they get a deer to piss in a jug
then they take that that wee-wee and
they go and they sprinkle it out so
another deer will come will smell it and
show up then when that deer gets there
they shoot that deer what do why are you
doing all of that I say man to man get
out there get a knife get two knifes get
a knife and a spoon if you want to fight
a deer quit you quit hiding from 700
yards away
dude they had a man the other day shot a
deer in Albuquerque New Mexico he shot
it from El Paso it's too easy with these
long-range scope scope pistols and
weaponry get out there and get a knife
get a fork and get out there [ __ ]
take a deer on one on one like a man
y'all out there shooting that [ __ ] from
[ __ ] you shooting a deer in Montana
and you shooting that batch from Boise
get out there man a man and get a deer
out there or not get a spoon out there
get a one big knife in you also you
don't get two good weapons you don't get
two knifes you get a knife and you get a
[ __ ] spoon boy and you get up on a
deer and you get him one time or you got
to get him get him up in the you know
hit him in that belly just you know yep
yep yep yep back them up in that deer
belly and then you you know get in there
and spoon one of his eyes out or do
whatever you got to do be a man shooting
a deer from three states away come on
grow up and be an adult and learn how to
kill an animal be a proper hunter that's
one thing I'll be honest I never liked
that [ __ ]
hunting you right there you guys are in
a deer stand you and your buddy out
there saying yelling lovers and y'all up
there drinking three things a whiskey
and haven't been home in a week and
y'all up there trimming each other's
beard hair you know and reading books to
each other at night you know what's
really happening out there Stanley
huh-huh Daniel what are y'all doing up
there you're playing tree house is what
you're doing and then finally at the end
of the week when y'all tired of each
other and y'all all out of beef jerky
y'all shoot a deer with a scoped rifle
from 900 feet away get out there like a
real man and fight a deer the
old-fashioned way get a knife get a
spoon and get out there and see who's
who you know I just I don't know some of
it seems and also I'm not a hunter you
know I'm not a hunter at all I'm more of
a you know I'm more of the hunted you
know I got beat up when I was growing up
by these two red-headed twins he's kind
of [ __ ] thick twins these big gingers
you know and and I got jumped by a bunch
of brothers a couple times and what else
and this one dude this one kid man this
boy he punched me and he was supposed to
be in our class dude this kid was 40
years old this kid was 40 years old he
had back hair
tons of back hair and some of it was
gray he had gray back hair and this dude
was in my class and he [ __ ] punch me
one time and I swear to God I saw the
damn Mayflower come over that boy he
just knocked my brain stem into the past
boy no I'm saying just sent me on that
pop that pop pilgrimage boy lit me up
you know I am uh I am happy to be here I
am happy to be here some news um I'm not
gonna say I might not be there yet but
we're figuring out these Toronto dates
so I'm now I'm still coming so I
shouldn't have said that but but I think
I'll still be there we're gonna figure
it out but I'm not sure
you know the festival is being kind of
wild so we'll see what's up but
September 14th and 15th I'll be in
Nashville I'm also gonna be coming up in
Charlotte Appleton Wisconsin Buffalo New
York Salt Lake City Washington DC all
those us all those are on Theo von comm
slash tour t oh you are we got some
calls man I'm gonna get into some of
them because I haven't gotten it as many
as I wanted to over the last few weeks
so I'm gonna make sure that we get to
some of those and let's get into that
right now thank you guys for calling as
always the hotline is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three onward
hey Theo this is Stephanie from Alabama
hey Stephanie thank you for calling and
the video that I was just in for that
Bishop gun ban was called Alabama did I
can't believe I got to be in a [ __ ]
country music video man I'm so nervous
not nervous I guess I just I don't know
dude you know I got them I just
you think videos is for more handsome or
people you know and I'm bait you know
I'm kind of more that basic look you
know my neck isn't super long and I have
you know my arms are only about medium
length you know that but I have you know
I got that as I got that polish eye
thing where it it looks like your eyes
are kind of just barely getting to know
each other and they aren't really
excited looks like both your eyes are
kind of asleep but also awake at the
same time and I got that wide nose you
know I got that kind of like a black
Italian guy and um I don't know I guess
I'm just kind of insecure about how I'm
gonna look on this [ __ ] shouldn't [ __ ]
matter you know so I don't know now I
sound like a [ __ ] dist weasel [ __ ]
whatever dude whatever bro I haven't
slept that much and whatever ladies I
haven't slept that much alright let's
hear more thank you for calling I'm
sorry I'm just making this about me look
at me homework in defense of
breastfeeding mothers with a tub okay so
you're saying in defense of
breastfeeding mothers with a cups and
this goes back to last week I was
talking about how I believe that
lot of children have anxiety if they
were breastfed on a cup breasts because
trying to get that milk out of that
little that little you know a little
leche rattler
I mean that's you imagine how
frustrating that is for a child let's
hear more because I'm one of them I just
want to say I don't think it's related
to anxiety because it actually has very
little to do with breast size your milk
production so uh okay we'll use let's
hear more so you have to blame your
anxiety on someone other than your most
food thank you I love the show have a
good one
well thank you for calling and I love
you I love you actually you sound like a
really nice person but I'm gonna say
this so you're saying from your side of
the bar that's your side of the bar that
there's no heed that the size of that
tot doesn't affect that milk production
well let me tell you what it's like from
the other side you know from my side of
the bar when you belly up to that small
breast man you just it's like going to
work when you get that big regular
breasts you know you see your buddy over
there and he got that big walrus in his
mouth and you over there just [ __ ]
trying to milk a cricket off your mama's
Little Lake cut that thing it does
create a lot of hecticness and it's hard
to get that rattle out of your out of
you for the rest of your life you'll
never forget how much you got a rattle
that milk out of a small breast but I
respect you saying you know the other
side of it and look there's two views to
every window
you know ohm word let's hear another
call hi I'm Lea my name I'll coach you
comment oh she's leaving her name how
boy so this is that dark Avenger right
here just Bruce Wayne up in here thank
you for calling young lady let's hear
more about young anxiety that you said
about the small boobs or whatever and
also about conception doggy style oh
yeah yeah I also believe that a lot of
children that are missed behaviors or
could possibly be conceived doggy style
or that how a child is conceived could
them determine how it
in life or how a person behaves because
I've definitely seen some of them
MDS bees baby them doggy style babies
and they uh they're often up to no good
so missionary conception if you want
more of a passive child I believe but
also with the [ __ ] do I know bruh but
thank you for calling in young lady
let's hear it I actually have some
anecdotal verification of that one of my
children was conceived on about the most
anxious child you have ever met
okay so Exhibit A right there this
lady's got that DSB you know share that
doggystyle baby right there and I can
that's Wow
it's wild to hear a woman that is a
brave enough to admit it and I commend
you you know you just straight-up Amelia
Earhart of being on your knees right now
you're you're brave enough to admit that
you conceive a child doggy style and I
respect that and I respect you young
lady let's hear more my other one was
not and he is chill as hell there there
are two years in two days apart there's
this same it's just weird
when you said that I lost it
proof baby this is proof right here a
son you know what I'm saying
call me Arthur Conan Doyle bruh we're
making real evidence right here alright
call me um you know Daniel day-lewis son
you know who else
Socrates baby we got it we got a little
bit of evidence thank you for calling
with this evidence young lady let's hear
more thing I want to say that I think
you have it wrong about Jordan Peterson
I really think that you could let loose
with all your humor and you would
appreciate it and be right along there
with you just a suggestion next time you
talk to him next time you have a minor
if you get that opportunity let it go
because I think she would actually
respond well well I appreciate you
saying that yeah I got nervous around
Jordan Peterson I yeah well here's the
thing I'm not an interviewer you know
like I'm learning as I go so a lot of
this is like dude this some of these
conversations are the longest
conversations I've ever even been in in
my
entire life so it's just like a word I
mean it's um sometimes in a conversation
is hot it's like it's like volleyball
for ideas but the ball is words and and
it's it's hard sometimes to be in a
conversation and to stay present and to
hear you know what people are talking
about and and that's something I want to
get better at man just listening to what
people are talking about um you know I
just want to get better at it I think
some of it comes us with peace you know
getting into meditation and things like
that just give you more peace and you're
not always thinking about saying stuff
this it's just seem like not fun after a
while but yeah it's interesting to hear
um I was nervous with Jordan Peterson
and there's a part on that you didn't
even see on that episode where I tell
him man look I'm nervous man you know
I'm nervous before we start right here
mr. Peterson I'm nervous and he was just
kind of he was okay with it you know he
was just cruising he was just cruising
onward um what else I'm trying to think
of anything else of wildest had that
that happened to me this week I mean a
lot of you know the music video was
crazy there was a baptism and there's we
were hanging out you know around this
fire and dance and there was antlers in
the head you know wha we're out shooting
in the Butte this beautiful hillside
outside of Nashville and you know like
they got all these fancy celebrities
live around there and it's just stunning
you know it was just stunning and I had
a good time just chatting with locals
chatting with people on set some man try
to break me off a little bit of an
Eightball after it a thing but after at
a campfire and I mean you know for one I
don't do drugs right now in my life but
for - honey doing cocaine around a fire
dude you what I'm saying I ain't that
guy ain't that guy who's doing cocaine
ain't gonna get railed up around a dang
higher place man that's just you waiting
for trouble cuz you get high enough you
think you're gonna [ __ ] pet that flame
baby you think you're gonna [ __ ] lick
that flame and then that's a rap white
and then your tongue look like a little
bit of a grilled Frank you know look
like a little bit of a um look like one
of them gas station wieners you could
buy let's take another call here thank
you for calling uh here we go APO
like the West Virginia hey Mike from
West Virginia thanks for calling in Mike
hope everything is going good out there
with West Virginia and sometimes I wish
honestly you you guys in Virginia would
just finish this [ __ ] off and see who's
who you know obviously you know I don't
remember when the quarterfinals were but
you got somebody beat somebody beat
North Virginia and somebody beat East
Virginia so it's really just down to you
my hunt so I wish you guys could really
find a you know get a couple referees
from Ohio or something and finish this
[ __ ] off make it easy on these children
who were trying to learn state capitals
cuz y'all out there messing around West
Virginia regular Virginia finish the
fight
okay finish the fight and it's gonna be
a good one dude West Virginia's got the
hills got the Billie's Virginia's got
you know they got Norfolk they got the
military bad boys is it you know it's
anybody's ballgame let's hear more ah
probably talking about million different
things as far as uh anxiety depression
and dark alerts but I'd rather call you
and tell you I was listening that
podcasting Mangini bus oh yeah man
Jeannie bust beautiful lady huh you know
and so charming man so charming let's
hear more and I see a little bit of
magic come on
alright love you well I'll just open a
Magic Johnson you see bruh um oh I think
she's uh I thought she was beautiful I
thought she was charming as well and
dude she dated a guy at the frickin
Verizon store
look everybody this is something look
this is a thing right here this should
be teaching us all it's about you got to
have that confidence you got to have
those rollover minutes up in your heart
you know I'm saying you got to have that
nights and weekends idea just swimming
in your spine because a man who worked
at a Verizon shop which could be any of
us almost any of us could work at a
Verizon even with felonies I think you
can have two felonies and still work at
Verizon Sprint won't do it I think
Sprint is one felony but you could have
two felonies and be up there at the at
that ver easy slinging celli's you know
and you and you can date the CEO of the
Lakers of the Los Angeles Lakers so know
whoever you are wherever you are today
we all got a shot if they got a good
woman out there now I'll say this
Jeannie bus ain't no thought she's a
regular lady she's got a big heart
she's you can tell immediately she's
extremely caring you know she's not
caught up in all the BS
she's a real woman she's confident but
she also she wants to be loved you can
tell that she wants to be loved by a
good man and and I think there's good
men out there they want to do it now
apparently you know that bad boy from
that cell you law couldn't handle it now
I'm saying he couldn't handle it so but
look it's anybody's ballgame every man
and our ladies got a shot we all got a
shot if you don't think you have a shot
then you got to change your perspective
man if I wake up in the morning I don't
think I have a shot then guess what I
don't have a shot you got to change it
dude that's one thing I you know what
I'm a friend of mine call me other day
man he's always calling me he's always
whining and he's always whining I can't
you know in there and yeah and
yeah well you gotta change it and
finally could I just said hey man I love
you but you got to change it you got to
change it
dude I'll tell you this if nothing
changes nothing changes that's the facts
if you think that something in your life
is just gonna change the look what how
it's not going to if nothing changes
nothing changes you got to change it man
you have to change it and you can do it
it's easy change here's the cool thing
about change if you change something
about one degree one degree in a year
man that's so minutes
the trajectory changes completely if you
change something that is flat that's a
zero or us a 90 or whatever it is a 90
degrees zero and you yeah zero and you
change it by one degree
that's upward then it's going upward it
went from going flat to going upward one
degree a little bit of effort you could
do it anymore no matter what it is you
know I'm saying you're trying to lose
weight don't have that second buttercup
you know don't have that second coconut
Buttercup at lunch if you haven't that
macadamia [ __ ] chocolate bad boy you
know you're filling your jaw up with
some you know bacon cobbler with the
pecan-crusted [ __ ] oatmeal sugar
shapeshifter you know don't have that
get you a little cut a banana and hit
you know surprise yourself with that
[ __ ] cut a banana you know get you a
you know cut a banana into four pieces
and play you know play baby dicks and
have a couple of slices you know and
throw them bad boys down all you got to
do with that one degree change about one
degree whatever it is whatever it is man
but if nothing changes nothing
remember that if we go through our lives
thinking something's gonna change man
it's not going to you know I'm trying to
I look I'll throw my [ __ ] coal in the
fireplace bro you know I'm saying I'll
throw my lint in the bellybutton right
now I got into a program so I'm trying
not to masturbate anymore you know cuz
I've fall off the [ __ ] lotion rails
every now and then I'll be cruising for
five or six days and then BAM that he
slips you know I greased my palms up
with that bad boy lotion and I'm going
to or three rounds with my own cat and
I'm tired of it I'm tired I'm tired of
jerking off bro
I'll admit it I have masturbated
probably 3,000 times in my life and I've
never won anything so I got to change it
man
so now I got me a little program where
it's like you know don't touch your dick
baby bear don't touch your dick baby
bear you know I got me a little program
I put the pornography blockers on my
computer and my phone I've never done
that before right those you guys who
listen to who've listened since day one
you know you know I'm struggled you know
I'm struggle with you know the problem
with your penis is it's hooked to your
own body it would be it would be easier
for me to Matt not to masturbate if
somebody else had my penis and they ran
around with it all the time and I had to
catch them and then you know you had to
chase somebody down to even be able to
jerk off
you know if they gave my penis to a
long-legged
you know young black lady I might never
masturbate because those young ladies
are usually very fast and I could
probably never even catch up to my own
wiener to do self-pleasure but the you
know the bane of our existence you know
apparently I'll let you know even though
the Lord did the work
I think Satan's snuck in as a
subcontractor because our penises hooked
right to us and as a young man these
days man it's hard out there with all
the pornography and like I said earlier
you cut on your phone instagrams and
they got some lady on you know you
waitin your little boys in there
brushing his teeth you cut on Instagram
for 30 seconds to kill time and they got
some lady on the front page juggling
around tits or something and it's just
you know we're doing magic with our ass
cheeks or something and it's you know
it's hard to come it's hard to you know
the sex is everywhere all these screens
wanting you to J alt and spray up and so
I'm tired of doing that I want to keep
my chi up I want to hold on to my
manhood and so that's what I'm trying to
do now if you don't have a problem with
and some guys out there these young
bucks are like I don't ever what are you
talking about what are you talking about
you know are you you know you you know
you trying to you're saying no you you
know no more ski ain't saying any of
that but I am saying that if you
remember a problem a masturbation you
don't have a problem with you know for
me when I don't when I don't feel good
or I feel here I'll tell you what it is
man
let's go into it I wasn't even planning
on having to think today very much cuz
I'm tired bro I'll be honest with you
I'm tired I'm tired man but I'm grateful
I'm grateful that I'm here and look I'm
happy to share whatever IQ no I'm a
happier here here so I noticed this
about myself when I was young I didn't
feel good and so once I learned you
could masturbate and some of y'all know
I snuck up my brother had a shelf he had
a closet you know and he had the shelves
in the closet on the top shelf
he had a stack at him you know then
pornography booklets you know them titty
literatures and so I you know I was up
there and he had a bottle of peach uh
Alize so I've you know
took off the capitai I'd never seen
pornography or had alcohol so next thing
you know I opened up that titty mag saw
the breasts you know saw that little
beautiful little law you know kind of
pink baby billfold that then ladies was
showing off and I took next thing you
know I was also excited I took a cup I
was sweating I was sweating on the top
shelf um you know I'm five feet tall I'm
up there on the top shelf all geeked up
on pornography my brain is [ __ ] my
hair probably grew three inches my brain
was so keyed up so I took a couple hits
of that Alizee the peach Alizee out of
that bottle and I took a couple of long
drams of that peach Alizee to cool off
and then I [ __ ] fainted Brown fell
off that shelf you know he wrecked and
drunk yes I don't even remember just
titties and alcohol all at the same
moment that vagine that crutch and daddy
couldn't handle it all my system gave
out my system gave out man
and not us remember just our members
being fully erect and just then just
black and out so anyway but I Dennis aw
you know after that you know I do learn
to do some self pleasure masturbation
you know shot you know masturbating
myself and I used to masturbate myself
and and I would do it and it felt good
so then any time I didn't feel good if I
didn't feel good just even as a person
or anything I would do self masturbation
just to feel good so it wasn't always
about sex for me you know and I don't
even realize this too recently it was
just about oh well I know how to make
myself feel okay I know how to make
myself feel good so I would do it just
to feel good so then I developed an
unhealthy relationship with touching my
own body
you know and being that little body
touch there
so anyway that's carried on a lot of my
life and I didn't realize it really so
now I have to kind of reprogram some of
the way
I behaved with all of that and all that
jerky action you know playing a freeze
tag with yourself you're rich you're
rich you're rich you're rich and then
you know you would Jack your Latin It's
A Wrap
so now I got a you know so now anyway I
got pornography blocker on my computer
and that's called covenant eyes there's
a program out there guys if you're
struggling this program called covenant
eyes you can put it on there and there's
another one called MOBA sip mo bi CI P
and you can put that one on to your
cellphone and these are programs that
can help you kind of keep it together if
you want to keep it together or you or
you can't handle it because the the
pornography is powerful that's all I'm
saying is that the pornography is is
powerful um I don't know even how I got
started on this conversation what was I
talking about
[ __ ] well if I was on to a different
topic before I forgot about it
new footballs coming back full steam I'm
going to fantasy football draft every
year you know I'm in this group of fan
of men with fantasy football and last
year some dude overdosed on some on some
marijuana chocolates and he this dude no
joke did lapse in the hotel room for
probably two and a half hours doing laps
it was a small hotel room it was like at
a Days Inn doing the last brothers did
was geeked up this dude was out there
[ __ ] just Carl Lewis anon himself out
there straight up you know Jesse Owens
brah I do guys so high he thought he was
[ __ ] Jesse Owens of the days in this
dude was doing the hundred meters in a
[ __ ] small hotel room so anyway this
year we're going to Cabo San Lucas
Mexico and the last time I was there I
got stuck in a category four or five
hurricane and this was in nineteen I
don't know 2007 or something and the
whole island got destroyed so hopefully
we'll have better luck this time but we
do a destination draft every year and
all of our group it's like my one big
trip that I do for myself every year and
we go somewhere and do something fun so
I'm looking forward to that
getting some beach time and just getting
out in the water and let mother nature
dust you know just kind of do that
full-body douse on me you know just
doused my whole skin because sometimes
even as a man you got to just douse
yourself from the outside or even it
from the inside dude if I have to I'll
get out in that water and you know if I
have to hold my buttocks open a little
bit and let nature get up in there and
wash daddy up you know get daddy I'll
even get my prenatal not prenatal what
is it
phosphorus levels yeah I think if my
phosphorous levels tightened up that
phosphorus balance that pH balance lets
to get another call here we go thank you
for hitting the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five two zero three
thank you guys for bearing with me this
weekend and I'm I am kind of tired and
and it's just a lot going on but I'm
grateful that we had this dude's man
some people who came out and bought some
nice gifts they had some brothers that
came out you know I love seeing brothers
go out you know and do stuff at the
shows together it's so nice when you
show up with your you know Sue had
hermano and you guys come together and
enjoy comedy together you know that
makes me feel so good we had some people
who came out it was their anniversary
their first comedy show ever a young
lady came out we had some people come
out you know that suffer from anxiety
and that you know just makes me feel so
good
you know we showed up to the comedy club
and we'll put this package together we
can meet you know meet our single mom
and Raquel and we showed up to the to
the comedy club and everybody was out
there waiting and I'm the snow is it was
exciting was exciting for me it was
exciting for me to share that moment you
know with the single mom was something
there's so many of us have had and for
us to give she was really really man she
was so cool and she you know we had some
good conversations talking about
motherhood and parenting and and and
just helping me think you know because
I'd like to have some of those things in
my life if I can get myself you know in
a position to be able to you know love
somebody and know that I'm not going to
make poor choices that are going to a
factor my relationship or that I'm going
to you know not be able to be honest in
a relationship you know I want to be
able to be an honest man and be you know
and care and conduct a positive
relationship so that I can have a wife
and family one day I think as much as I
know I want to give it a shot you know
anyhow so we had a great time let's take
some more calls here we go hey Theo this
is Xavier from Milwaukee thank you for
calling the Xavier homeward wanted to
tell you about my past weekend because I
had a really awesome just amazing
weekend man oh good congrats man and if
you have a best or worst weekend hit the
hotline let us know what it is only if
it's really great or really bad once a
month we'll pick a winner and send you a
prize package onward past few years I've
been living on my own after getting
kicked out of my parents house just due
to some family religious issues oh man
religious issues you got kicked out of
your folks baby hey that's the lower
brother that's the landlord it sounds
like homework
um I've been living on my own ever since
and I've been you know working that
whole time over time whether it's ft ot
homework high-rise window cleaning
roofing or anything but oh you that
squeaky bad boy out there that high-rise
window cleaning dude you that freakin
Evel Knievel out there with that Windex
that [ __ ] and that bad baton that
[ __ ] squeegee Luigi you out there damn
Wow bro that's the cert so limpio
that's a cert they soar limpio a spanish
first circus so cleaning bro you got to
get out there and clean them winders
homeward I uh I got a new job and I
actually just got promoted this weekend
to mentor so now I'm going to be like a
trainer and stuff for uh for anyone that
comes in to to work with me at my store
as a salesman and I also just closed in
my first apartment with my fiancee Wow
bro what oh that's a huge you got a huge
stuff going on man do congratulations
and I love hearing that I love
part of the curious crew of people that
listen to this show and that are part of
this show or enjoying themselves and and
that are achieving some of their goals
man damn a savage bro more and we just
had our wedding shower last weekend so
it seems like this year in the past few
years has been filled with crazy amounts
of stress and work and my back-breaking
labor but finally after after hustling
and keeping my head down and working
hard as I can every single day it's
finally paid off and I just wanted to
share that with you anyone else who
feels that they might you know be in a
bad situation or not have control of
something going on in their life but if
you put in the hard work and you do
everything you can to achieve your goals
it's possible and that you know those
people hold all the power
Amen bro amen man you know you know
hearing you say that dude honestly look
I bro right now no joke I feel like my
voice sounds clearer right now I just
sound like you just put it you put me
right where I needed to be it's one foot
in front of the other nothing changes if
nothing changes but you changed
something about one degree and you keep
moving that something forward bro you
can hit the moon you can eventually hit
the [ __ ] moon you don't have to go 90
degrees straight up you just need one
degree and it's one foot in front of the
other and that's the thing that we learn
by having guys like Jordan Peterson and
Jocko willing kin here it's like you
learned that you have it is this life is
an effort game it's an effort game yes
some people you get the easy some people
do have it easy but the the value the
[ __ ] fun is in the struggle it's in
the journey bro it's waking up every day
and feeling like you can be [ __ ]
Eminem and not Drake who was born out in
Calabasas and he had it easy but you
could be a man in or you could be easy
you know or you could be Selena it's
waking
with that chip on your shoulder but
putting that chip to use putting that
chip on the table and saying I'm gonna
bet on myself not just walking around
angry man name my whole life no
put the [ __ ] chip bet on yourself
nothing changes if nothing changes you
got to make an adjustment and here you
got a young man out there he got kicked
out of his that folks house because he
didn't want to Lorde up you know I'm
saying maybe and maybe he was too old to
be living at home you know you can't be
a 31 year old altar boy you know getting
$5 a you know a week from the church you
know out there cuz you out there
slinging uh you know slinging the
pastor's little smoke bucket or whatever
that thing is that little watery that
water handle that he has where he beaten
people with you know not beating people
with beat in the air with a little water
stick you can't be out there altar boy
in your 30s bro you got a G up and you
got out the house and now you got an e
now you have a firt you got a place with
a lady and you're moving onward so now
it's about what's next for you what's
next maybe you'll get a vacation home
one day maybe you start a fan you you
gonna keep on notch in your belt because
you put one foot in front of the other
good if you can't think of what to do is
get vertical that's the number one thing
I noticed this about myself when I am
horizontal when my brain is sideways my
brain does it no wonder I'm not making
good choices when I'm laying down cuz
I'm not my you look at your head it's
obviously meant to function upright you
get yourself upright and you get one of
your feet moving and then you that for
thee and then hopefully your other foot
gets jealous and I hope that your whole
life you have jealous feet now when one
of them moves that other one [ __ ] gets
jealous and a sellout will go Moo well
I'm gonna moon and then the other ones
like that look I can go moon well uh no
moon and next thing you know you takin
three four or five steps and next thing
you know you've done a lap and next
thing you know
you're moving onward thank you for that
call mana congratulations that is that's
a great month and I appreciate you
calling about that your best worst
weekend with the promotion let's hear
another what's up this is Mark I'm
calling from Indiana
oh [ __ ] mark from Indiana oh and a lot
of people came over from Indiana to
Chicago this weekend and I want to thank
you guys
dude it was so cool man you know like it
was so cool I wish I got to spend more
time with the with everybody that came
out this past weekend that's a lot of
nice people do gave me you know a couple
of gifts this lady gave me this
beautiful little necklace um you know
this cloth like a little religious
necklace uh a man gave me a uh oh
a young lady gave me a coffee bro mug
but I don't have it at the house I want
to wash it out first because that thing
you never know and and then what else
somebody gave me Oh Edgar Allan Poe doll
like it's not a doll but like a little
bobblehead and so yeah I want to be able
to we were trying to get some shelves
and stuff put in this studio and then we
can you know have some nice
accoutrements and curios that people
have dropped off to us so long the week
but man you know I felt like so I had so
much fun
dude I had so much fun and I have fun
meeting people man and you know a lot of
hugs a lot of handshakes a lot of people
sharing thoughts in the future be cool
to do something where we can hang out at
some point during the weekend huh maybe
we can put something like that in next
year you know we'll see man it's also
crazy there's only so much time in a day
let's hear more on what I was calling
about the best worst weekend this past
weekend I actually went skydiving for
the first time and everything went well
those probably one of the best things
I've ever done in my life and here's the
kicker
whenever I landed I fractured my ankle
in two spots so I just thought I'd share
that with you guys and keep doing what
you're doing
I love listen to you thanks man dang man
I'm sorry to hear about that ankle bra
you got
and bad tarsals huh your tarsals got
banged out and a lot somehow you might
need a marrow up you might need to drink
some milk or something you know lay off
that orange juice and get you a [ __ ]
get you a couple gallons of whole milk
soak that thing you got a broken wheel
soak that [ __ ] in a bucket full of milk
or cream or milk and butter that's
old-fashioned
remedy but I'm sorry to hear that man
but look I'm glad that you went out
there and did some skydiving do when you
leave out the plane how crazy is it bro
when you leave out the plane man that's
cool well I'm sorry you hurt yourself
bud you know you got one you got one
good ankle though you know what I'm
saying I would tie your one leg around
your other leg and put a roller skate on
your good foot and [ __ ] get at the
top of a hill and have somebody you know
kind of push you forward just a couple
inches get that Momo that Menem started
and [ __ ] BAM boy head down he'll pick
up steam and [ __ ] see what you hit
baby change the world baby change the
[ __ ] world
all right let me tell you about this
dude because some of you guys don't even
know about this
this is beardbrand some people will be
saying we'll deal what are you having
your hair you know a lot of people come
up and pet me and [ __ ] like that when
they see me a lot of raccoons if you
have if you walk by somebody's house and
they have a raccoon the raccoon a lot of
times will look over at me if they see
me they think I know something that
other people don't and that's because I
use beardbrand I use beardbrand sea salt
spray in my hair I have it in right now
boy I put that temple smoke on Masada's
his beautiful kind of cream do it's this
smokey scent it kind of salve that you
can kind of put in your hair just gives
you that musky kind of that man tint
it's it's beardbrand and it's premium
men's grooming for beard hair and skin
they formulate products to work with the
body's natural
and that's one thing I will say when I
put on that beer brand stuff I feel like
I'm just you know it's almost something
that's from like the Wild West or
something it's something it's almost
like it came out of another man's bone
marrow and I'm putting it on to me and
it's helping me to kind of beautify
myself but also take care of myself it's
based out of Austin Texas there you go
Texas probably one of my tops four
favorite states man great state great
people and it encourages men to be
themselves there's nothing wrong with
being a man there's nothing wrong with
it
the mission of beer brand is to foster
confidence through grooming beer brand
is more than products it's also
education inspiration and community make
sure to grab the utility bomb which is
great anywhere you need it beard hair or
skin
it's a moisturizing product that softens
hair and breathes life into your skin
you can head right now I got a gift for
you you can head to beardbrand dot-com
that's B ei rd b ra ND dot-com / theo th
EO today for a free sample of that sea
salt spray if you can't make it to the
beach bringing a beach to yourself it'll
automatically be added to your first
order sea salt spray adds texture and
volume to your hair giving you that
beachy hair Oh where's where's Jerry
Bennett oh he's been ooh at the beach
that's beardbrand com / theo for a free
sea salt spray you don't have to do
anything just put in the coat just go to
that link keep on growing all right I've
got some other calls are popped in and I
want to hear some of them man I haven't
heard any of them let's go hey what's up
deal this is John I'm calling right now
from middle of nowhere Louisiana oh man
well thanks for cup thanks for calling
man pick up a hitchhiker dude take your
chances you know what I'm saying
pick up a hitchhiker bruh roadside
roulette I'm on a road trip right now
from Jacksonville Florida to Dallas
Texas just headed back to school and
driving through the backroads of
Louisiana made me think of a
question for you what kind of stuff did
you guys do growing up in high school
for fun
like there was this kid on American Idol
I don't know if you've seen him if you
haven't you should check them out he's
awesome
Naima Layne Hardy he's from Louisiana
and when we Brian asked what kind of
stuff he did for fun he said I'd just
like to drive my truck around and then
Katy Perry asked Oh what are you doing
driving a truck burnings at all I just
like to burn gas so I just want to ask
well if that's the kind of stuff you
guys did drive your truck they're
offering gas let me think about that
that's a good question what do we do I
think you know I mean we did drugs I
remember at some point we did some good
drugs and bad drugs too you know I grew
up in the bad Ellis and the bad acid
belt and a lot of bad acid would come
through our area
the armor and one time we got real high
on some acid and um cooked up pizza and
a dryer and it took about four cycles to
do um on permanent press to do a medium
and it comes out as a calzone you put it
in as a pizza and it comes out more as
like a calzone or just like a hot kind
of ball of Italian what else did we do
that's a good question what did I do
well I used to walk a lot you know
because I didn't there was something
weird before I got a car I didn't want
to be seen there's an age where you
don't want to be seen on a bicycle like
a bicycles too much for children so but
you know and you don't have a car yet so
you walk so I will walk a lot you know
so I walk five six miles to get
somewhere to do something you know good
at arcade or something and what else did
we do ride around you know I used to I
used to get a bicycle and I get a
bicycle I was mean steal one out of
somebody's yard and sometime it could be
anybody's bicycle I'd take that sucker
and I bike over to my girl's house I had
this little you know beautiful little
white girl I was seen as she was you
know they're you know that rubenesque a
little bad girl you know
and we go over there and I sneak up in a
room and it had a cat
they had this grey cat I had to sneak
past this little [ __ ] bra and he
was always trying to start something
with me you know like he like we had met
in a previous life and I'd done
something wrong to him you know like
maybe like a couple hundred years ago
he'd been you know it was eating a piece
of fish or something by a river and I
came up and stole that carp out of his
hand and so you know now he's out here
he's trying to get back at me so
whenever I go into this girl's house I
sneak in through the laundry room
they had a door to the outside you go
into the laundry room and come into the
kitchen
well that cat this little gray hitter he
would hide in there they had all these
towels and you know dryer sheets and
stacks of all kind of stuff or whatever
in the laundry room so and it was pitch
black and I couldn't cut the light on
because you're worried you know you
don't want light going out under the
door into the kitchen what if the moms
walking down the hall or whatever you
know I couldn't have the family see that
I was sneaking in so I'd get in that
laundry room and it dude it was like the
laundry was about 9 or 10 feet long to
that from one door to the next door and
it was just a gauntlet bra and every
time like clockwork that little gray
[ __ ] come flying off on one of
the top ropes like Jimmy Superfly Snuka
and just do that four leg drop on me
yeah I mean just and then it was on boy
it was on and you couldn't even see us
it was just this dark like fiasco
and then you know I'd make it up to her
room and then and then the cool thing
was so then I'd get into the kitchen
finally get away from that little Mundt
you know had a little deal and I'd then
I have to sneak up to her room and the
stairs went over her parents bedroom so
you had to like real stuff step on the
sides of the stairs that was a trick
don't step out in the middle of the
[ __ ] stairs like somebody that never
broken anybody's housing before step on
the side of them steps you know so
really the way the wood is strong and so
it doesn't make any sound you get up to
the top and then go sneaking old girls
bed and we lay in there and do that's
when you were oh man
that's about when you were young love as
a teenager everything was strong bra
your whole body was just all just caught
up with horror moans you knowing them
hormones were just [ __ ] brought your
eyebrows would just do my eyebrows used
to do laps around my eyes bro you could
see my eyebrow just literally doing
circles around my eyes I was so just
horny you know I would just be so fun
just so funny that my eyebrows would be
dude they'd run off behind my ears dude
do all kind of [ __ ] you know my eyebrows
were running or they've run around did
chasing each other around behind my back
like a couple of squirrels brush you
know squirrels do with different sides
of the tree they'd be like that man I'd
be so horny bro that my eyebrows would
just run right off my [ __ ] face dude
that's how horny I be my eyebrows would
just run right off of my face and just
just like squirrels chasing each other
around my body and I'm laying there and
make out with my girl you know I mean
that's what I did as a teenager outside
of that what do we do mm then it's funny
I'm have to think about what happened I
don't know it's a great question I think
my brains also this a little bit fried
today but thank you for taking some of
the backroads and thanks for for calling
him and I do appreciate you being a part
of this past weekend and it's funny as
you're doing that I were acting just for
imagine you driving through my state you
know I met a girl at student council one
time and she lived up in Ana Coco
Louisiana and man I fell in love with
that girl just in a moment I fell in I
mean there was something about her and
it was Samantha and she battled cancer
not too long ago and I believe she's
doing well
[Music]
and she was beautiful inside and out she
was just a million different shades of
beautiful and uh and I met her a student
council convention and then the schools
I had that year our school hosted it so
all the schools had to drive back to
their school and so they left on that
bus and that's back before they had cell
phones and stuff my heart was just like
my heart left with her and I was just
the skeleton just wandering around you
know that's and that's something of my
young love it's like you literally don't
you remember feeling like somebody else
had your heart like they had it like
they physically had it and you were just
this birdcage without a bird and I yeah
just remember that guy and so then did I
remember calling their school and
leaving messages I put two letters in
the mailbox before that bus was forty
miles outside of our town and all our
remember was her name was Sam that's all
I remember
and so they I remember calling do that I
don't even know if this background I
guess the school had a voice mail I
remember calling the school and leaving
a voice unlike the vice-principals voice
mail saying hey this is gonna sound
crazy but uh I met one of your students
this past weekend at the at the student
council convention in Mandeville
Louisiana and I fell in love with her
and you just got to let her know that so
anyway uh later that year she invited me
to go to their prom and so I drove up
there and uh man it was special it was
just a special time so that's something
I think and look and I was always when I
was young was trying to be in love I
would fall in love so fast so fast
because I wanted to be in love I wanted
to be loved so bad and I wanted to you
know I just wanted love in my life I
didn't have it in a lot of places in my
life innately and so I would do things
outside of myself to try and get
involved you know I'd fall in loving a
[ __ ] dam I fall in love brah
I was that dude man you know I was that
you know for show me oh I was the for
show me Oh room you know just I mean
just on a decline just about to ready to
fall in love let's take another call you
know what is going on what is going on
man thank you for calling
homeward this is a Rodrigo con from
Mexico Oh hola Rodrigo que paso Senor so
I'm originally from Mexico but I now
live in Canada been living in California
now I'm living in Toronto Oh
bonito bonito [ __ ] this CMOS man is sort
of falls out cannot I cannot en yo soy
now I'm gonna bail out of that sentence
let's hear more so I'm just calling them
to let you know some news and big news
uh my girlfriend and I were moving over
this other city across Canada called ten
more Alberta reason being because the
best skiing in Canada is there the best
cross-country skiing so I have a huge
dream man I want to share with you I
want to represent Mexico and the Winter
Olympics and the cross-country skier
dude that's awesome man bro you're
putting your dream out there this at
first I think this is a first on this
past weekend is somebody putting their
dream right out there you want to be the
first wait let's back this up a second
man look back this Jam up dude cuz I
want to hear a little bit more other
city across Canada called Canmore
Alberta can more Alberta yep onward
reason being because the best skiing in
Canada is there the best cross-country
skiing so I have a huge dream man I want
to share with you I want to represent
Mexico and the Winter Olympics of the
cross-country skier Dan
you want to represent Mexico in the
Winter Olympics as a cross-country skier
dude that's fascinating I love that man
I love that dude tell me more so I'm
trying to get the [ __ ] job [ __ ]
Beijing 2022 yesterday night we got we
finally got this off this apartment it's
two bedroom apparently to move into and
really excited and like my dream is
finally coming true
drew Matt so I'm gonna be training for
four years over there obviously 2018 to
2022 and I love the show I love you my
girlfriend I listen to you all the time
much love and much peace to you oh you
all mente amigo he will maintain man Wow
you are you're chasing your dream dude
and you got a lady there to support you
and you are a man and you to support her
man that's beautiful dude dude that's
awesome did that so it's so cool man
it's like it made whatever I'm doing
right now it makes me feel so much more
worth it you know just knowing that
somebody's out there chasing their dream
bro
dude you're gonna be a you're gonna be a
Mexican cross-country skier yeah I don't
know if I've ever heard of that dude I
remember when I was young I um I wanted
to be the first person to see do around
the entire world this is probably 25
years ago our 20 years ago I sent and I
sent a letter to see do to the company
and see do her though they make those
like jet skis and I wanted to be the
first person a jet ski around the entire
world and uh and they never wrote me
back but good for you man good for you
from one to do something unique and
thinking of something unique you know
it's so funny cuz sometimes I think oh
there's nothing left that's new out
there that somebody could think of or
somebody could do and then BAM baby big
bad boy Roderigo headed north de Rodrigo
O'Day North thing that means Rodrigo of
the north best of luck to you man best
of luck to you and your lady in that two
bedroom and bro you just do you've
already achieved so much
just by by by changing it up nothing
changes if nothing changes boy and
anything is possible right now for
Rodrigo onward let's take another call
vo this is Jason from North Ohio so when
I was a young I was younger when I was a
kid me and my sister were playing a
Ouija board and we were talking this
little girl her name was Nadine ooh
Ouija board that's the devil's padlock
right there son more and she died in a
house fire
so we get done playing and right as I
get to get up my sister goes Nadine we
be Jason's girlfriend and guess what a
little clinker - where the hell they
call it slide - yet so I've oh yeah dude
ghost will [ __ ] anybody bro let's hear
more ghost girlfriend okay stop for
couple days later I have a date with a
girl on the satyr on Saturday and then
ended up going to sleep on a Friday
night before and my house caught on fire
so I get rushed out of my house I'm
outside sitting in a car Fire Department
shows up then when the fire got
firefighters come up two men are like
why were you smoking in your closet I'm
like I wasn't smoking in my closet
this didn't keeps grilling me saying
I'll smoke on my closet mmm I didn't
smoke so the ends up labeling the fire
as suspicious
most fire is suspicious - do you know
I'm saying if you're standing around
somewhere usually there's not fire so if
there is fire that's suspicious more
eventually and inclusion that today's
okay well that called us cutout ah damn
gentlemen what's a second you know what
to say man it's telling Nadine doesn't
want you messing around at all or
sharing any of her secrets it sound like
you also could be on drugs dude you know
I'm saying y'all got weed you boys out
your [ __ ] house is burning down man
you might want to go back to school you
know you might want to take maybe some
mom you know trying to look at that GED
that GED or some you know JUCO you might
want to check out a JUCO brother and see
about some things you know maybe do
medical billing or get into something
like that best of luck out there do cuz
if you're out look man if your life plan
is you gonna be out there [ __ ] ghosts
and collecting insurance money for
burning down properties well I guarantee
you're not gonna get very far let's hear
another call I feel Susheela first of
all I love you and just want to tell you
that thank you Sheila I love you too I
was wondering how did you come to live
in Tucson Arizona
I heard you mentioned that you used to
live there I'm actually from Tucson and
I used to see a lot of UFOs so I'm
curious how did you end up in Tucson
what were you doing there and did you
see anything paranormal while you were
there I didn't see anything paranormal
I saw a pregnant girl beat up this
[ __ ] this gang this Latino gangbanger
one time at a car wash and I'll never
forget that [ __ ] dude she picked up a
stick off the roadside and beat this
dudes ass and she was hella pregnant she
was like 11 months pregnant like this
baby already should have been enrolled
in like daycare something like she was
so that's the only real paranormal thing
I've ever seen there I think my mother
moved out there when I was in high
school I went to live with a family I
got emancipated when I was 14 and you
know when sit kind of getting to moan
stuff and uh and my mother moved out to
Arizona and then at one point I was I
was struggling with
I was struggling with life when I was in
high school and I moved back out to live
with my mom and she lived in out in
Tucson and we lived out there off a
golf-links road out there on ah in East
Tucson and you know what I liked about
Tucson was man there's a lot of good
people there there was a lot of good
people and I missed some of that and no
worry you don't have to have shirt
sleeves you could be anywhere you could
be running a [ __ ] bank you could be
the manager at a chase bank and not have
to have any shirt sleeves and always
found that to be special but thank you
for calling and I'm glad that you've
seen aliens let's hear more hi do my
name is Kayla from Boston Massachusetts
hey Kayla more a boyfriend I just moved
in we've been together for a year and
there's a little you know little things
here there that I'm starting to notice
that he does like I have a lot of pet
peeves but there's one that's definitely
been my driving me nuts and for some
reason he loves like opening up a
cabinet in the kitchen we've taken out a
mug and just keeping that cabinet open
so there's like 12 cabinets open in my
kitchen all the time and it's kind of
prison yeah okay I'm not this is
supposed to be happening like this but
is you I think you might have a ghost in
your house that's what this sounds like
are you sure you have a boyfriend
because this whole thing somebody's
seeing a go says Ouija board house is
burning down
you got cabinets that are open all the
time yeah I guess it could be pissing
you off let's hear more and he said that
I should you know pretend to like knock
my head into a cabinet and go like ouch
and I grabbed my forehead so he comes
rushing in well this in now that sounds
like a lot of extra work what I think
you should do is just let him know you
don't like it when he does that and if
it continues to do it then maybe find
you a man that don't mind you know what
I'm saying
they don't mind closing that box up
every now and then you know cuz here's
the thing if you leave that cupboard
open somebody else is gonna slip up in
there and use the [ __ ] dishes you
know what I'm saying
somebody's gonna get up in there yes so
you guys good luck out there with each
other I love you welcome this is
from Frederick Maryland a Jason thank
you for calling it from Maryland I'll be
up there in Washington DC later this
year I don't know where but the tickets
are at theof on comm slash store onward
art or tou are onward I got a question
for you man I got a friend Josh she's a
pro MMA fighter she's out here with both
big fans of your show and ever since you
dropped that line the spot Wyler we both
thought that that was him like
immediately after you said it this man
physically personifies the word Scott
Weiland that thought Wyler and a thought
Wyler is you know it's a best that bad
boy that you know stays on top of him
thoughts and don't let them ladies be
out there it is you know them ladies get
out there and they you know waiting in
line at the club and they you know got
on that champagne neck gloss these
[ __ ] out there with that champagne
neck gloss song and they got them high
heels with the you know goldfish
swimming around and a high heel you know
and all of that [ __ ] dots out there and
your boy he's an MMA fighter and you
said the name fits him homeward and we
were wondering if for his MMA name if we
could call him the thought Wiley is you
would be hard with that oh praise the
Lord brother I'll be happy if you guys
want to call that dude the thought
Waller dude I'll be happy if you guys
get a tattooed across his [ __ ] neck
you know what I'm saying do you get a
tattooed inside of his mouth nobody will
ever know except for us but I think you
should also there's a Native American
guy that called a couple of weeks ago
and he wants to use it as a you know
like thought like dances with thoughts
or something so that's the only
competition you have with you sure can
brother you guys are more than welcome
to use it man so thank you very much for
uh for calling in and asking about that
man let's take another call right here
here we go hey Theo uh big fan man this
is Nate in Denver Colorado was so big
Nate from Denver Nate Nate Nate Nate
Nate
that's Nate come on really hoping you
get some stand-up orator out here I'm
sure I missed it but really hoping to
see you live one day man but anyways you
were talking about how you had a little
a little pee hole but you had a man's
dick oh yeah I was born with an adult
penis and I had a small small wiener
opening where the urine came out of in a
very fine stream I mean I could wash a
[ __ ] I could wash a cookie crumb off
of a [ __ ] roaches back from 9 feet
away and not miss own word and and you
had you had it surgically opened it yep
they got in there get in there and crack
daddy open boy and then I was just I had
that wide mouth bass all of a sudden if
you will I could fill a coffee cup in
less than a second just want you to know
I just sighs I mean I feel your pain bro
I kind of have the same issue I didn't
have a man's dick when I was four
unfortunately but yeah I know
fortunately you mean bro it's not fun
for a child of a man's unit on him more
just wanted to know what the surgery
kind of entailed because I'm kind of
scared to get that done I don't want any
anything happening to my business well
do look imitates if you need the surgery
you need the surgery
this ain't no optional thing I didn't
get my wiener widened open that hole
wide open for fun because I wanted to be
the dude you know you know I wasn't
gonna get a huge wiener holes if people
could just balling beer out of my wiener
you know or do urine bongs out of my
body it's not for fun brother I had to
have it because I had that heavy flow
coming out of my front and I had that
funny and it was it burned I had to pee
so because the urine there was too much
pressure and the hole was too small and
so I was shooting 16 17 feet you know I
mean I was just you know I could walk
you know I could wash a grain of salt
off of a [ __ ] you know like a washer
grant dude I could [ __ ] walk I could
knock a grain of salt off a big girl's
eyelash from probably 90 feet or whatnot
90 feet not maybe 16 feet away not 16
feet maybe 9 feet so that's what I'm
saying it's not optional if you if you
if it burns when you go you need it but
if you do need a man good luck getting
there brother and I love you man be good
man
onward let's take another call here man
take 2 more and then I'm gonna shut it
down I know if I seem a little out of it
today man it's just because I am bottoms
a little bit tired homework hey what's
up he is Brian from Roanoke Virginia hey
Brian from Roanoke and that's where
Plymouth Rock I think they got Plymouth
Rock over there let's hear it on last
week's episode you gave that breakdown
of the Poirier Alvarez fight which by
the way it was really awesome oh thank
you man yeah I'm you know I'm a fan of
the diamond baby Dustin Poirier and he's
in Florida now but he's that bad boy out
of Louisiana you know and he and he's a
family man and I feel like he seemed
like a decent role model for people and
it's hard to find good role models these
days and one of the craziest things was
do to him and PMP platinum platinum Mike
Perry they we all follow each other on
Instagram so you know we would be really
really blessed to have one of those guys
in here and I'm working on it I'm gonna
see what we can do you know be nice to
be around somebody who has that kind of
confidence and just uh and see what life
is like through their eyes that would be
a really special time we could have all
work definitely love to hear more of
those in the future but I don't know if
you watch the post-fight interviews
before EA said that when he had Alvarez
and that guillotine showed that Alvarez
actually gave him a wet willy to try to
get him to let go of it just wondering
what you thought of that man crazy stuff
all right thank well look I think when
it comes down to you'll do whatever you
have to you know what I'm saying we Nick
when it's when it's you know it's your
last breath
you'll do whatever you have to do you'll
hide half of an elbow you know you give
somebody that [ __ ] that Korean goose
bro you know when you put a little bit
of mustard on your elbow and [ __ ] put
in somebody's ass I mean you do whatever
you got to do to survive you hit them
with that [ __ ] cagey boy you throw a
little bit of Dijon up on you know
mother nature's arm antler right there
that elbow [ __ ] hide it right up in
some new sphincter you know and it burns
so much because that star bra that must
start that it just they have to let you
go so you got to take care of yourself
whatever you got to do wet willy that
Korean goose whatever you got to do you
know fighting this fighting and you got
to take care of yourself and you got to
think up about yourself into care number
one let's take one more call here here
we go thank you guys so much for being a
part of this past weekend man I you know
the the thing that's really kind of
making me a little bit I think shut down
right now is just honestly do not
feeling so much gratitude you know so
just so many nice people come out to the
shows and it just makes me feel good and
it makes me feel excited and um yeah
dude it's just like you know and it may
it's Fondy when people are laughing and
you're telling me tell them telling them
my story and you know that they can
relate to it somehow or they're like you
see like a couple laughing together you
know or you see like they'll have a [ __ ]
you know it's known father/son he'll
come out one of the guys I worked at the
Laugh Factory brought his parents out
and man they were so nice and it just
you know and their son was really nice
and you could tell it just makes me feel
good to just you know know that
sometimes there's some families out
there and stuff that are just having
Joey you know and I can be a you know
like I can be a little bit apart of that
it makes me feel like a part of you know
it makes me just feel like a part of
things
you know cuz that's all we really want
to feel like you know in the end our
whole lot all we want to feel like we
just want to feel a part of things I
just want to be a part of I just want to
be a part of I just want to be
I just don't want to not feel alone you
know and so it's so nice when I see
families that come out to these shows
and they're enjoying the stuff that
makes me feel so good let's hear more
one more call here here we go
hey Steven out here in Utah just
finished listening to your podcast
thanks for calling Steven homeward I
think last week we were saying you
wanted to feel like you're a part of
something bigger yeah man I was just
saying this dude I swear to god I do
have no idea that this guy's was gonna
say a part of that's crazy man yeah
there's just five calls left here on the
sheet and this is the one that I picked
homeward but I'm just saying man like
your podcast is something bigger you're
having people calling around from the
country you know all over helping each
other out with each other's problems
creating ideas and thoughts that people
are sharing you know even if we're not
all in one place you're putting these
ideas into our head and you know we're
all on that that frequency you know
you're putting us on that frequency oh
thanks man you know thank you bro so
nice you just say yeah I'm happy to be
um you know I'm just part of it like I
think of it as like we're all kind of
like this curious crew you know and when
I come to the shows it feels like I get
to come and see you guys that's what
it's like for me I get to come and see
who else is involved in this weird [ __ ]
we got going on and we're gonna keep
doing cool [ __ ] man I was just talking
with my producer Nick today you know
about about us actually doing that the
the cleaning lady or the maid thing
where we hide a game show in a hotel
room and we surprised the cleaning lady
and we videos hidden-camera video it and
make an actual game show so you know
it's a chance for them to you know just
have a good time at work and you know
make some money and do something fun you
know just kind of change their day up
you know and just remind us all that
like you know if we you know like our
day can change it may not seem like it's
gonna be the best day but that anything
can happen
you know if I go out under the day every
day and it's like I already know if I
already think all today is gonna be like
this then it probably will if I already
think oh man today just another today it
probably will but if
walk around thinking man anything could
happen the next conversation I have with
the guy that I've had a million times
might be different
anything could happen anything could
happen if you think that meant anything
could [ __ ] happen bro but thank you
for that man all work in tune it's nice
man so don't feel like you're not doing
much man or you're not part of something
bigger like you create something bigger
man you are a part of it it's just a
family you created with the the past
weekend podcast man so looking forward
you're Salt Lake show man looking for
geniu much love take it easy
gang bruh gang gang that's nice of you
dude that's nice of you to say
yeah well I'm happy to be one of the one
of the crew hands you know I'm happy to
be one of the people you know that's a
part of this group and that includes all
all of us man I don't feel like a
[ __ ] you know I don't like this is my
thing really you know and that's what I
that is one thing I like I like I feel
like a responsibility as part of this
group that we're gonna do some cool
stuff and we don't even know what some
of it is that's the cool thing we don't
even know what some of it is you know
when we started we didn't know we
started thinking oh well let's do what
we want to do something for some single
moms out there so now you know we had a
great time this weekend respond and look
out dude the last thing I wanted to do
on Saturday when I woke up man I was man
I've been working Monday through
Saturday I've been working traveling
work just all of it I did not want to
because there's something inside of my
brain that tells me sometimes that I
don't want to do stuff but that's my
brain something's wrong with my brain
sometimes because my heart when I'm when
I'm when I'm thinking about what I do
want to do my heart is giving me good
ideas and I was so grateful that I got
up and put one foot in front of the
other and made my way over to the
Michaels craft store and got some
different canvases so we could make the
pain
so we could do the um the single moms
afternoon and she brought her friend and
they were dance instructors and they
both had children her friend had twins
her friend had twins and she had a
little daughter when she said that the
husband she didn't say anything bad
about him she said that they have just
you know he wasn't as on board maybe he
didn't want to be the daddy didn't you
know he wasn't really super into it and
then we talked a little bit about just
like what it means today to be a couple
and uh you know and what it's like
because I'm learning from these ladies
you know because it's scary to think
about getting involved and then you know
if something doesn't work out or if it's
or if something doesn't work out how do
I handle that you know if I do end up in
a relationship in a marriage and then
and then I don't end up in it well how
can I best serve the mother of my
children you know not that I'm planning
these things out ahead but you know
there's always an opportunity to learn
but I'm just glad that I kept my feet
moving and then we had a great time and
there was one point in the show where I
heard uh Raquel laughs where I heard her
laugh and man that made me feel so good
it made me feel good bruh you know it
made me feel good that she was just with
her friend and they were having fun and
it made me feel good as a man to help to
help to have let two women have fun let
them have a good time and they don't
feel any expectation to me you know they
don't owe me anything they don't owe me
anything all they had to all that the
only thing didn't even all they just by
having fun they gave me everything I
ever could have asked for by hearing
them laugh and joke around and it was a
joy and I don't get to do that without
the people from patreon support
and we're given uh a well and we're
gonna do a follow-up call with them and
I don't know if I already told you guys
what we're doing for the her and her
daughter as a gift we're gonna do
something nice for them but this whole
thing is evolving now and now we kind of
know how to handle the single mom thing
and what to do and we're learning as we
go
but we're keep moving onward one foot in
front of the other we start off with one
degree let's talk about it then two
degrees let's do let's do let's change
it let's do a little something and now
we're at like [ __ ] fifteen degrees
with this thing and it's cruising and
it's a group effort man but I feel
grateful to be here with you guys today
and I'm just I had a great time thank
you very they came out in Chicago thank
you very natural and that Bishop gun
tour on the bishop gun video that dude
that video is so crazy man I don't think
I'm much of an actor but I'm excited to
see what this thing looks like I'm gonna
take y'all with one of my favorite songs
by a man who donated his music to us
right in the beginning of all of this
podcasting mr. Spencer a Jacob growl uh
is there anything else on this list that
I need to do note that taking a sign up
a better help calm slash Theo if you're
having some trouble you can go to aware
study org if you want to be a part of
that study and you can also go to
beardbrand they do have good products
I'll tell you this man there's one thing
I will never ever hopefully I'll never
do I'll never sell you a Casper mattress
I don't think because I don't think
those mattresses are comfortable and I
will I'll never say something I don't
think is is good you know I mean I hope
that you'll be able to try everything
that we ever put on here as ads and I
hope we can always continue to do some
ads for small businesses and I'm a
[ __ ] sometimes and if I do all
apologize you know but those are the
things that uh that you can go and check
out yep beardbrand comm slash Theo and
you'll get that free sea salt spray for
that hitter for your head you guys let's
get on out of here
be good to yourselves man you probably
deserve it I bet you probably do I bet
if you ask yourself really you know you
probably do too man love you bro love
you lady be good bye bye Gang Gang
[Music]
spencer jacob growl
celebrate living
[Music]
celebrate our day
celebrate all y'all
side
let's have some fun while we all die